un soldat d'élite
qui rentre à la maison je suis content
que tu sois rentré et qui découvre une
conspiration
nos anciens compagnons d'unités font du
trafic de drogue il est arrivé
au sommet le lieutenant ross importe de
la drogue dans ce pays depuis des années
la production d'opium en afghanistan est
plus importante que jamais il y a un
gros problème je règle les problèmes
ses compagnons d'armes sont devenus ces
pierres et demi
mais s'ils veulent la guerre ils vont
l'avoir tu peux me croire vous avez
déshonoré votre bébé pendant des années
je me suis battu avec fierté pour ce
pays
tous les hommes ont un point de rupture
on va commencer par là
key
par devoir
pour l'honneur mais les bouchées doubles
par justice
michael jai white
max ryan
steve austin pour est de tuer là
maintenant
justice armée